hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season 8
episode 9 the mid-season premiere titled
honor and guys welcome back to new rock
scissors breakdown of The Walking Dead
where I take a closer look at each
episode to explain any lingering
mysteries and point out some of the
things that you might have missed now of
course it's hard to focus on the details
after an episode that was such a gut
punch no not Carl's dead
Morgan literally punching a dude in the
gut and ripping out said guts Kalima
style dude just leave something for the
walkers right barf
I'm gonna get to Morgan's psycho killer
turn later along with the impact of
Carl's death on the world of the show
but first let us start with the big
question brought to us on Twitter by yo
G the flashback of me and with Judith is
mind-blowing is that gonna happen and
what we're talkin about these closing
shots there was also this tweet from
Alex asking about that final final shot
of Rick laying on the ground bleeding
you know the one next to the tree with a
stained glass hanging from the branches
yes these two closing shots are both
very intriguing so let's talk about them
first we see the final part of the old
man brick future vision with future
Judith skipping up and saying hello to
of all people
negan holy crap oh yeah in case you
missed this it was revealed this episode
that of all these warm fuzzy visions of
the future that we've been seeing all
season were really corals fantasies
scenario happy ending he just dreamt up
unfortunately one that will never happen
at least not like this like this
remember in episode 1 Carl only appeared
briefly in passing making a joke about
the music in those visions that the bulk
of that vision instead focuses on Rick
and Judith and the other happy residents
of fantasy Alexandria that's because
Carl knew he would never be part of that
dream scenario or at least it wouldn't
be the star of it instead Carl just
hopes for a future where Judith listens
to the music he liked and Rick is so
merciful in this war that he figures out
how to live with negan as a peaceful
functioning member of this society now
again we're still meant to look at this
imagery as a fantasy extreme a work of
Karl's imagination in reality
just got bombed guys Jerry and Eugene
aren't necessarily safe and ningún while
arguably capable of peace probably isn't
gonna turn to Old MacDonald farming
tomatoes so while it's interesting to
see the future Carl had in mind there
are still lots of different ways this
could go which brings us to the final
final final shot of the episode this
also gives us more context to imagery
that we saw back in episode 1 with
Rick's sad eyes looking up at the
stained glass here a wider shot shows us
that rick is actually wounded and
bleeding
curiously it's in the same region of the
body as where Carl was bitten though I
don't think this was a bite wound I
think what we're seeing here is some
vision of actual future events with Rick
in the midst of battle perhaps post
battle and the location of his injury on
his lower right might be leading him to
recall his son's final moments as for
what could have caused this injury I'm
gonna bring up something from the comics
so if you don't read The Walking Dead
comics and you don't want to get spoiled
skip to this time got it see I'm giving
you a chance to save yourself so don't
be a dope and complain in the comments
that I ruined anything for you go on
skip okay as you comic readers know in
the final days of the Saviour war negan
orders men to slather their weapons and
Walker guts so that when they wound
Rick's people they infect them this
clever move causes a scare when Dwight
still pretending to be on negan side
shoots Rick in the gut with an arrow
luckily we find out that the arrow was
clean and Rick survives to negan
surprise this leads to a final
confrontation with negan the two bar
ket's each other their philosophies Rick
cuts negan's throat just a little bit
negan breaks Rick's leg and Rick
pronounces the war over as the order
some vegan to be treated and imprisoned
so perhaps what we're seeing here is
Rick's suffering from a similar wound
now I don't see any arrow in this shot
that says revolver right aside there but
maybe Rick is just wounded close to
death leading to this mercy prevailing
over his wrath and decision to end the
war with negan in custody not executed
now if you listen closely here Rick does
say the line my mercy prevails over my
wrath this is a callback to the season 8
premiere sadik's poke this line and
was echoed by Karl to Rick now Karl has
been urging his father to adopt a more
merciful forgiving worldview that
challenges them to rise above their
vengeful wrath Rick whispering the
phrase here suggests that worldview
might actually influence his actions in
the near future at least when it comes
to negan let's actually run through the
other connections to past episodes in
our segment callbacks seeing this this
was Carl's goodbye episode we got to
walk down memory lane for his character
with lots of nods to past moments all
major life moments for him first there
was his fatal blow with a replay of that
moment back in episode 6 when old
choppers got a piece of him this time
the camera stays in close on Carl's
reaction showing us his full thought
process as reality sets in on him later
on with Judith Carl tells his sisters
sometimes we got to show our parents the
way this is also callback to that
episode 6 episode it's a direct quote
from a line that he said to Sadiq when
they both talked about their parents he
also passes on his iconic hat to Judith
he mentions how it used to belong to
Rick he gave it to his son in season 1
and Carl wore it to feel strong like his
dad is maybe giving Judith this hat
could end up being a passing of the
torch moment like future teenage Judith
could end up playing the function young
adult Karl plays in the comics Carl also
references his time at the prison in his
final moments he talks about his
mother's death something this moment
with Carl is definitely intended to
parallel he quotes her final words when
she said that he was gonna beat this
world and now he passes on that promise
to Judith he also references the kid
that he shot shortly after that the one
who was surrendering but Carl shot him
anyway remember that was Jodie the boy
from Woodbury Carl brings him up as an
example of his merciful attitude that he
now wants Rick to embrace he says that
ruthless violence is just too easy to
fall into in this world so it's
important to rise above it
Carl discusses this while the episode
intercuts with this debate between
Morgan and Carol and Ezekiel over what
to do about Gavin Morgan's ethical
dilemma is the practical example of the
hypothetical Carl is talking about there
so it's thematically appropriate that
the one dick
kill the surrendered man is once again a
boy Henry following in Carl's prior
footsteps here Henry represents the
danger of this easy violence that Carl
is warning us about actually notice how
the final shot of Gavin is a direct
centered frontward facing close-up I
think those are meant to evoke the
iconic shots of Rick's people during
Meegan's infamous lucile lineup this
framing seems to be The Walking Dead's
way of hinting at condemned figure the
moment before their execution let's
actually look closely at a few other
subtle interesting visual choices made
throughout this episode in our segment
zoom in enhance so in addition to the
intercutting with Carl and Morgan you
may have noticed our earlier Carl's
description of his happy ending future
in her cuts with these images of Rick
and Michonne tearfully digging a grave
on a metaphorical level this editing
choice suggests that Carl's naively
hopeful dreams might be getting buried
along with him also notice how Carl's
face gets coated and dust from the
bombing overhead this is an interesting
effect on his skin tone during these
scenes making him appear even more pale
and lifeless kind of like a corpse
collecting dust it's almost like Carl is
slowly transitioning to a walker before
our eyes as he makes his goodbyes giving
all of his words more of a ghostly
beyond the grave wait but some of the
most interesting visual choices this
episode involved how Morgan was shot
there was this one menacing shot of him
walking up the theater aisle trailing
the injured Gavin as he tried to escape
also there were three separate shots
that showed saviors escaping
disappearing from frame but as we
expected the camera to cut away the
camera is left rolling showing what
seems like a few seconds of nothing
important but then Morgan slowly enters
the frame like a real creeper these
extra seconds of the camera left rolling
build suspense within us setting up
Morgan is kind of a jump-scare this
cinematography along with the concerns
reaction shots from Carolyn Ezekiel
paint Morgan as a frightening villainous
figure this whole episode this technique
is actually something we've seen in
other well-known horror films so let's
move on to the other possible cultural
influences in this episode in our
segment under the influence yeah I hope
you like these segment titles as much as
I do okay this letting the camera roll
move
has been used in a lot of horror cinema
recently in Paranormal Activity the home
video is left recording on a static shot
endlessly building tension until a
shadow moving or furniture or a ghostly
presence just slides in the frame this
effect is similar with Morgan here he's
not heroic he's scary the guy is gonna
stand over you while you sleep for hours
and hours
also notice Morgan's slow deliberate
movement he chases after Gavin with a
sense of inevitability like Michael
Myers in Halloween or the Terminator
there's no mercy here Morgan is a
killing machine while we're talking
about cultural influences here notice
the tension of the characters as they're
in that sewer tunnel underneath
Alexandra as it gets bombed the steady
booms and rumbles begins to undo some of
them mentally this could be influenced
by a moment in history when British
civilians in London had to go
underground to wait out German
blitzkrieg those unnerving overhead
booms became a regular part of life for
in wartime London for all those people
and a lot of you guys were asking about
the song that plays during Karl's final
Day montage this is at the bottom of
everything by bright eyes it did at
first seem a little odd to hear this
happy sounding guitar tune over these
sad moments but if you listen closely to
these lyrics it's all about embracing
the end during a plane crash and that's
exactly what Karl's doing here making
the most of his final day hanging out
with Judith feeling the Sun on his face
writing goodbye letters to Rick Michonne
Enid does another secret crushes see
that Perry apparently had but let's move
on to the deeper meaning of this episode
again this episode was called honor and
for me honor seems to refer to the way
Carl wants rick to fight this war with
negan it doesn't have to be a killer be
killed winner-take-all philosophy for
Carl the more honorable approach would
be for his dad to let his mercy prevail
over his wrath in the real world test
case that we see of this dilemma with
Morgan debating with Carol and Ezekiel
over whether to execute Gavin it's
interesting that for a second at least
Morgan almost seems like he might let
his mercy prevail to a violent psycho
killer rediscovering his humanity this
gives us hope that Carl's worldview
might actually succeed in the final days
this war unfortunately Henry going
through with this execution reminds us
that actions have consequences and the
violence of our choices might as it
almost did with Carl inspire the darkest
behavior in the younger generation
hopefully Carl's death will have more of
an inspirational effect on these
survivors with torch bearers like Sadiq
and Judith left behind to carry his
legacy and his message for troubled kids
like Henry to hopefully hear it and
let's check in on our kill count this
episode guys how could it be anyone else
Morgan who by my count took down at
least eight saviors this episode one of
them gutting them like a fish
Morgan is quickly approaching Daryl to
become the deadliest character on The
Walking Dead when it comes to on-screen
kills and to think this whole bloody
revenge journey began with tabatha the
goats a question for you guys which
character death do you think will have a
bigger impact on Rick Carl's death or
his wife Laurie's death comment down
below to let me know your thoughts on
this and on this whole mid-season
premiere in general or tweet me directly
at EMS and follow new rockstars on
Twitter for updates on our videos like
this video and subscribe doing rock star
is for deep the obsessive analysis of
The Walking Dead and make sure to follow
all of my breakdowns from the past
episodes of this season for all the
other stuff that you might have missed
and if you really want to help out this
channel and help us grow you can
contribute to any small amount you feel
like to us on patreon big thanks to all
of our donors especially Kelly hopper
guys thanks for watching see you next
week bye